[Music]
it is time now for a CBS deals this
morning we have a few things that may
make your day go just a bit smoother
with these Time Savers for the new year
and all at exclusive low prices so start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Ashley
Bellman joins us with more good morning
good morning Happy New Year 2023 the
year of ease ease yeah we need some
means okay so starting with this product
this is the Limitless phone station and
cup cargo two different items this one
is 19.99 this one's 27.99 this you put
into your cup holder in your car hook
your phone on there so you can navigate
safely this one is the cup holder and it
holds those big giant coffee cups that
ever fit in the car like ours like a set
mode Christmas gift yes super adjustable
the savings up to 30 33 percent off and
I love this because it's going to fit
your big phone even in that big case
both items because if you use one you
can't use it for the other it's perfect
exactly and you can change it
horizontally vertically however and it's
higher super yeah and also all the gunk
that gets in that car holder you don't
get that here okay oh I need I need a
manicure okay this is for all of my DIY
girls who are great at painting their
toenails at home don't want to take that
trip to the salon this is called Salon
step I never paint my nails at home
because I can never find a comfortable
position Now problem solved okay this
you put your foot on here you can adjust
it to your liking you have a little gel
insert so it's comfortable for your foot
magnifying glass LED light fan spot for
your nail polish I mean we never have to
go to the salon again this is a game
changer it is Comfort it is ease and I
mean truly for 20.99 40 off think of all
the money that you're saving not having
to go if nothing else your daughter or
your son might love it yes it's just to
have fun yes okay so finally grocery
shopping you know when you go to the
grocery store and it's just first of all
plastic bands are in effect in most of
the country we like this we love this if
not plastic free is the way to be this
is the Lotus trolley bag it comes with
these bags you put them in your cart you
can stay organized
grocery shopping one of them is
insulated you can make sure and
especially checking out that you put all
the things that go in the pantry in the
one bag you put all the things that go
in the refrigerator in the other bag
there's a slot for your wine there's a
slot for your eggs there's a produce bag
these bags are beautiful they're
washable you could actually take the
bars out and throw them in the washing
machine use them as totes this you will
never forget at home because they are so
lovely to use is an optical illusion or
do they get smaller with the card as you
go they adjust yes yes they start
smaller they've got everything and I
just want to show you how you just can
easily look with the insulation this is
incredible my husband's actually the one
who does the grocery shopping in the
house and he is going to be obsessed oh
my gosh so how much again this is 34.99
for everything for all of them 42 off
yes and you get the produce bags too and
I love that yeah yeah that's I mean and
the thought of it all pocket for your
book
so if you're waiting in line
nobody reads in the grocery store little
magazine you never know nobody
like I said I don't
know thank you so much Ashley of course
we partner with all of these companies
to get these great deals so to buy
anything you saw today scan that QR code
on your screen or head on over to
cbsdeals.com